the 28th annual summerlin council
patriotic parade rolled out today to
celebrate our nation's independence day
hundreds gathered along the parade route
to see more than 20 giant inflatable
balloons and over 70 floats christian
casares shows us some of the excitement
a sea of red white and blue along
village center circle in summerland as
an annual tradition continued on this
fourth of july the music was fun and my
favorite part was a marching band this
year the summerlin council patriotic
parade was back after the pandemic
paused the celebration honoring our
military and keeping the las vegas
spirit alive so awesome this is so well
needed it's so great to see everybody
together again not wearing masks we can
see their faces and the whole community
coming together
more than 70 floats made their way from
hill center drive and hill point road
around village center circle to spring
gate lane our very own brian loftus and
sherry swanks on the mic as a parade
strolled by the reason that the
summerlin parade initially came together
as kind of a grassroots effort in the in
95 and we certainly are proud to carry
on that tradition
las vegas now mercedes martinez and jc
fernandez also hosting the parade while
more than 50 thousand people cheered the
palo verde high school marching band and
the nevada latino arts and culture
association among others it's very
special all parts of the community are
represented and it makes you happy to
live here 25 giant balloons colorful
floats and even lady liberty kept the
crowd smiling as hundreds of american
flags waving along the parade route i
just loved all the beautiful music and
all the beautiful floats and everybody
was nice christian casa is live local
now
the parade is organized by the summerlin
council about 2500 people were in
today's parade more than 500 local
volunteers helping putting it all
together again